[Musique]
à conques un grand toit
et que moi aussi je crois toi
[Applaudissements]
il n'aurait pas pu faire ce que tu as
fait
[Applaudissements]
quand tu sortiras 10 il faudra que tu
leur montre que ces toiles chef
tout le monde sait que c'est moi non je
lui fais pas confiance
[Musique]
sortir ramasser tous alors qu'on gère le
business depuis plus de trois ans
je lui dois tout
je me demandais de tout gérer entre
l'absence de faire tourner la machine et
c'est ce que j'ai fait
le contexte a beaucoup changé écouter
très attentivement là rien ne changera
tant que c'est moi qui décide
écoute moi le travail est trop dure pour
tout abandonné toujours lente
montrez lui que c'est toi le président
de manière à ce que tout le monde sauf
moi
c'est moi présidence et compris soit
vous êtes avec moi sont des autres mois
c'est que t'es pas le genre de mec qui
s'enfuit face aux difficultés
tu l'aies
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]